françois souvent fi général de brigade
expert en géostratégie bonjour merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rfo alors
une stratégie de sécurité nationale
réviser car les menaces ont changé d or
niveau de la nature je parle là bien
évidemment du cyberespace et des dangers
qu'elle comporte
oui tout à fait de toute façon je crois
que tout payé aujourd'hui conscients de
l'environnement cyber en particulier
mais pas uniquement en considération ce
qui peut attaquer aussi bien je dirais
ses infrastructures civiles que ces
infrastructures militaires sous toutes
leurs formes
l'informatique est partout de cyber est
partout donc ce qui a été à nouveau
d'ailleurs redit par le président
poutine est tout à fait cohérent avec ce
que font la grande majorité des états
aujourd'hui pour parler un des menaces
étrangères on sait que la russie a une
politique étrangère plus tôt
indépendante
en tout cas pas calquer ans sur certains
pays occidentaux à quel point cela
peut-il déranger je ne vois pas en quoi
ça peut déranger qui que ce soit chacun
dans son pays est maître chez soi chacun
dans son pays pour les mesures
nécessaires pour se protéger des
intrusions étrangère celle est valable
pour la russie c'est valable pour les
états unis
c'est valable aussi pour la france et
quelques autres pays donc en rien de
bien anormal dans la cette vision de la
sécurité nationale c'est de la
responsabilité d'un président d'un pays
et qu'elles font aujourd'hui les actes
hostiles 1re qu'elle est confrontée la
russie je ne sais pas si la russie est
soumise à des actes hostiles puisque
jusqu'à présent ou du moins au moins
dans la presse rien n'est ressorti d'une
quelconque attaque contre la russie dans
ces domaines là en revanche je me
permettrais de dire que on accuse
souvent la russie d'avoir mené ce type
d' attaques contre les états unis contre
l'allemagne contre la france notamment
lors des élections alors effectivement
avec le cyber on ne sait jamais d'où
vient la tacc exactement on ne sait
jamais à qui l'attribuer
mais les soupçons pour l'instant on
plutôt dans une direction que dans une
autre
alors que maintenant le président
poutine réagissent dans ce document
important
ça s'est il faut bien le site et c'est
normal puisque finalement ça moyen de
dire attention venait pas magrets séchés
moi je prend les mesures nécessaires
pour assurer la protection des citoyens
russes et des sociétés russes
personnellement je maintiens que je ne
trouve rien d'extraordinaire à cela
c'est normal et je crois que tout
président responsable ferait la même
chose alors une stratégie un pour
renforcer comme tout pays les capacités
de défense de la russie parlons de
l'aspect militaire en la matière la
russie étant un leader elle fait
d'ailleurs partie des puissances
militaires mondiales
oui tout à fait mais là on a abordé le
cyber la ronde et vit effectivement sur
les capacités militaires
la russie a montré depuis 2015 avec son
intervention notamment en appui de la
syrie qu'elle était capable de projeter
des forces qu'elles étaient capables de
mener une guerre lointaine qu'elle était
aussi capable de tirer des missiles à
longue portée
donc je dirais qu'un directement ce que
vous poser comme question et la question
du réarmement d'un certain nombre
d'états aujourd'hui que ce soit la
russie que ce soit les états unis que ce
soit pas tout même la france
il y a une certaine incertitude sur
l'avenir du monde aujourd'hui et on voit
bien que les dépenses d'armement chaque
année augmente désormais pas forcément
d'ailleurs dans les étapes d'une cité
mais globalement ce qui veut dire que
les risques de guerres aujourd'hui sont
loin d'être exclue maintenant entre ces
pays que je viens de citer le risque de
guerre me semble peu probable en
revanche l'intervention militaire dans
d'autres pays me semble beaucoup plus
vraisemblable alors stratégie de défense
1 qui vise également réaliser les
objectifs de développement nationaux
quelles sont les conditions dont la
russie a besoin aujourd'hui pour doper
sa croissance économique
alors là c'est une question qui serait
plus pour un économiste mais je dirais
que à un grand un poste d'exportation de
la russie est quand même l'armement
depuis très longtemps l'art moment
fourni par la russie est important à
l'étranger donc comme le fait la france
d'ailleurs depuis deux ans l'industrie
d'armement fait partie du monde
industriel par lequel il est capable
effectivement d'avoir de développer de
saines croissance
la haute technologie et puis aussi de
faire appel à de nombreuses intelligence
donc un facteur de croissance économique
maintenant ça ne suffit pas il me semble
que dès lors qu'on est dépendant de
l'exportation de ces matières premières
cela peut poser problème si on prend le
cas de la russie que vous venez
d'évoquer effectivement dès lors que on
exporte une grande partie des bases
commerciales est assurée par
l'exploitation de gaz naturel ou de
pétrole que en face qui achètent en
grande partie l'europe d'ailleurs un je
crois que c'est 26 % du pétrole acheté
en europe est acheté à la russie environ
40 45 % du gaz naturel donc une certaine
dépendance qui s'est créée aujourd'hui
de la russie vis-à-vis de ses
exportations
donc je dirais que si on devait élargir
le débat c'est est ce que les sanctions
aujourd'hui d'une européenne à
l'encontre de la russie ne met pas en
difficulté la croissance future de la
russie merci françois morency d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes général de brigade expert en
géostratégie mercière